les doy la bienvenida al espacio de
cultura de france24 arrancamos este
programa con las series más esperadas
del año son dos precuelas de exitosos
universos fantásticos y se estrenaron
casi al mismo tiempo la casa del dragón
en hbo Max y el Señor de los Anillos los
Anillos del poder en prime video la
primera en llegar a las pantallas a
finales de agosto fue la casa del dragón
y cuenta una historia que acontece 200
años antes de la serie que rompió todos
los
récords Juego de tronos Y si la casa del
dragón lograra sumergirnos una vez más
en este mundo de intrigas políticas
guerras y monstruos que escupen fuego
gracias a un reparto impecable parece
tener un universo un poco limitado
frente a su hermana mayor o Juego de
tronos y sobre todo en comparación con
la precuela de la Obra maestra de
tolkien El Señor de los Anillos los de
poder solo con el primer episodio que se
estrenó el 2 de septiembre se podía
sentir que esta serie es un estupendo
regreso a la tierra media los anillos de
poder acontecede 3.500 años antes de la
saga del señor de los anillos con la
puesta de adaptar El material original
de este universo México a nuestra
modernidad con por ejemplo personajes
femeninos más poderosos y visualmente es
una maravilla de planos efectos
especiales y trabajo de la luz un éxito
a la escala de su precio
465 millones de dólares lo que la
convierte en la serie máscara jamás
producida veamos el trailer
[Música]
este mes Argentina celebró El regreso en
forma presencial de uno de sus eventos
más representativos de su cultura el
festival y mundial de Tango de Buenos
Aires es un gran encuentro anual que
ofrecen Cumple tu muestrario de la
cultura tanguera y río Platense se
pueden admirar a los consagrados del
género conocer a las nuevas generaciones
y enterarse de lo que está pasando en la
escena tanguera contemporánea nuestro
corresponsal natalyoko soy nos presenta
esta edición desde la capital argentina
[Música]
se llevó a cabo en Buenos Aires la
edición del año 2022 del festival y
mundial de Tango de la ciudad que está
íntegramente dedicado a la música y el
baile típico de la capital argentina se
presentan más de 1.500 artistas en unos
a 30 Mercedes en el contexto de este
festival exhibiciones de baile con
ciertos musicales también es clases y
otro tipo de presentaciones vinculadas
con el tango en la ciudad y por supuesto
esto milongas las típicas milongas de
Buenos Aires espacios de baile donde la
gente se reúne a practicar el tango que
es algo que sucede a lo largo del año
pero ahora se da en el contexto del
festival como milongas itinerantes como
esta la milonga amapola en el barrio de
recoleta y otras 13 que participan del
marco del festival en algunos casos se
presentarán también en las milongas a
bailar los participantes las parejas que
compiten en el mundial de Tango son
parejas de unos 30 países que vienen a
ver si se convierten en las mejores de
esta competencia muchos turistas que
vienen a Buenos Aires y que se suman
para todo lo que es la grilla artística
de festivales porque gustan de conocer
que está sucediendo con el tango como
una de las improntas fuertes de la
República Argentina
vamos a hablar ahora de los estrenos
musicales que nos cautivaron esta semana
Empezando por la nueva canción del
artista multidisciplinaria francesa a
Luis Ceballos cantante rapera pero
también bailarina actriz y artista de
circo sus habilidades la ayudan a
trascender las fronteras de las
disciplinas artísticas y a ser capaz de
expresar sus emociones de una manera muy
orgánica con letras y ritmos que
acompañan siempre al cuerpo como en su
último tema Love la historia de una
ruptura amorosa
[Música]
y del lado de los clubes los
estadounidenses Major Lazer se unieron a
la exitosa nigeriana siwa sabes y a los
dos hermanos de Sudáfrica mayor y Djs
para estrenar
un tema muy actual por su ritmo
característico de amapiano un estilo de
música electrónica sudafricana que se
convirtió rápidamente en un fenómeno
internacional
[Música]
Nos despedimos con las voces mágicas de
los brasileños una blacky y yo tape que
forman el Dúo agua estrenaron el tema
VeTV extracto de su primer álbum de
escoger noise Gracias a ustedes por su
confianza y sigan con nosotros hay más
cultura en Francia 24.com
[Música]